in southern turkey buildings crumble
like sand
[Music]
obliterated by some of the worst
earthquakes in a century
[Applause]
the first struck Before Dawn as the
country slept
the impact captured on a shop CCTV
shaking for around 90 seconds
[Applause]
the terror and scale of the damage
revealed with the light
the number trapped beneath the rubble is
unknown
the death toll is rising and the
aftershocks keep coming
a second 7.6 Quake rocked the center of
the country making the rescue efforts
even more dangerous
[Music]
there was um
you know more than six points magnitude
and he did cause a certain extra damage
not just only hampering the rescue
airports because I did see on my way
this is my second visit here some of the
buildings that were uh that looked fine
before were also damaged
the earthquake was incredibly powerful
unleashing widespread destruction
without warning a force so intense it
wiped out history in seconds this 2000
year old castle among the wreckage
salt
at 4 17 am we experienced the worst
disaster of the century since the 1939
Erza Jan earthquake
the earthquake whose epicenter was in
parachuk in karaman marash and had a
magnitude of 7.7 as per the latest
estimates was felt in a very broad
region
survivors are being found here a child
is pulled from the rubble
the next 48 hours are critical for
saving as many lives as possible
for those still trapped rain sleet and
snow are slowing down Rescuers with
temperatures expected to drop below zero
in the coming hours
dozens of countries have already pledged
Aid the UK is sending 76 search and
rescue Specialists with dogs and
equipment
for survivors time is now the greatest
threat
Siobhan Robbins Sky News turkey